- At this point, I'm basically in shock.
A violent mob has stormed
and seized the US capitol
for the first time since 1814.
And I have a lot of thoughts.
I'm sure a lot of people do.
I feel a great sadness for this country
and also a lot of rage
focused on a select number
of our country's supposed leaders.
While I will spend a lot of
time compiling those thoughts,
there's one that leaps out
and that is that we need
to impeach Donald Trump immediately.
14 days left of this
presidency is 14 days too long
and who knows how much
destruction will happen
in those 14 days, both
physically and metaphorically.
The 25th amendment is too
good for this president.
He needs to be impeached
and removed immediately.